the whole tone of this there's such a
real melancholy undercurrent in the show
how did you guys balance the comedy the
mystery and the sadness that hangs over
it all was that something you ever had
conversations about or did it feel
natural
came out that way
[Music]
well we did have conversations first of
all you know this uh blend comes from
many sources starting with the writer's
room
and then uh starting with the
development of the characters and uh and
then time shooting uh but a lot of the
episodes of we call it more sober
experiences really from from the writing
yeah i thought it was such a great blend
between all of that it just
it makes this whole
the whole murder mystery of it all is so
interesting and and i absolutely love
the dynamic that develops between this
trio
what did you guys most enjoy about your
own little trio as actors by the time
you got to the end of making this
what did you most enjoy about working
with and spending time with each other
well i think that that
again an actor can only control
the experience of of working on it they
can't control the end results you never
know
um and i think we all appreciated that
so everyone was there to have a great
time to make the crew laugh to make the
atmosphere
um
seductively positive and i think we all
shared that instinct there's a saying in
weightlifting called no pain no gain
but it's the opposite in movies
pain no gain
uh so we made it a point to sort of get
together and get along and get the job
done and have fun while we're doing it
but when you talk about lifting weights
and you're in your gym
what are you pressing i'm plugging my
i'm plugging my new gym
equipment line oh gosh
selena what was this like for you i mean
did you ever not go home with your face
sore from smiling i mean it seems like
you would just have so much fun
yes to be honest it was very fun um
i mean
constantly laughing even in the silent
moments it was just comforting to be
with these two because i mean i was in
quarantine so they were
the only friends i had during that time
and he was stuck
but i had i had a wonderful time and and
working with both of them i think it
made me
want to step up my game more it made me
want to be quicker um
it was so much fun and they they made me
feel like i was part of the game
after everything that these characters
go through how did you feel when you
found out where it would all end up are
you rooting for someone else in this
building to be murdered so that you can
all do another
season think there's a lion in the show
we say maybe we'll get lucky and
somebody else will be murdered
[Laughter]
it seems like such a terrible thing to
wish for but at the same time it would
give you another season to hang out
together
well
and also they're actors who are murdered
so it's a little bit different well what
was your reaction to learning how it
would all turn out were you guys
surprised with the outcome did you have
a sense of where it was going i was
surprised and when i finally found out i
thought oh that's that's good yeah yeah
same i was so sorry we didn't really
know until about the seventh show who
did it
the three of you are also listed as eps
on this so selena particularly for you
what did you want to bring to the table
creatively when it came to your role was
there anything specific you wanted to
have a voice in when it came to her what
was really wonderful is being able to
create
mabel as the show went on i think that
was what was really special because i
think
that now i feel more like mabel than i
had the first episode when it came to
her wardrobe when it came to you know
certain things that i didn't think were
cool um or somebody my age wouldn't say
i would you know that was very
comfortable and and going to talk to the
writers or john hoffman and
um
yeah i just wanted it to be great and
hopefully if it continues being able to
be involved in who she is is is really
fun for me
steve i love
the show that your character we get to
keep seeing bits and hearing bits about
the show that your character used to be
on and
and it seems that there are also many
reboots happening of your old movies
is there one of your movies that you
wish you could revisit on your own terms
movies you can't just say okay we'll
change it and make it better it doesn't
mean it's going to be better it's like a
movie like dirty rotten scoundrels it's
just like the fun of making it the the
way it turned out and everything and i
wouldn't change that and but why would i
go back and struggle with another movie
trying to make it work or not work
i mean i
i'm sorry i don't have a good answer for
you but i i just don't go back that's
the thing that's that's my answer i
don't go back that's a good answer
well martin what did you also enjoy
about working with nathan lane and
adding that kind of crazy relationship
to the mix
well i mean that you know nathan is an
old old friend of mine but we had never
worked together
um
so
that was really really
tremendous satisfaction for me
to be have such a history with someone
but now create something new that you've
never experienced before
did you guys
have music to listen to on set did
anybody get to come up with a playlist
that you listened to
only selena
selena was the queen of playlists
i will say i had great moments where i
was you know singing some billie
holidays some linda ronstadt like i had
my days but every now and then i would
spice things up and i would play some
rap songs that weren't
necessarily appropriate but the reaction
was golden so i did yeah
a few rap songs won by cardi b
yeah
oh you're going to hear about it selena
you're going to hear about it yeah yeah
this is all over
a lot of complaints
i love everything about sting playing
himself in this including the fact that
he's a bit unlikable in it how did he
get involved was he did it just feel
like he was game for all of this
oh he was completely game for all of it
he came to the set
knowing every line of long speeches
enthusiastic
focused and endlessly
being funny and charming yeah he was a
lot of fun he had a great sense of humor
about it
and fun to be with us off the set off
the screen too when we're not shooting
seems like you'd have to have a really
good sense of humor just to he does yeah
i've known him off and on for many many
years
and always found him charming he and his
wife trudy
styler
selena after conquering the worlds of
acting and singing or at least doing
pretty great at both of those things are
you surprised to add hit cooking show to
your resume now
i have to be honest i thought i was
going to do one season of that and that
it was just gonna happen but i had
so much fun doing it that i wanted to
keep going so i am a little surprised
because i'm not the greatest chef in the
world but i suppose that's what makes
the show good so
um i had i have a blast doing it never
would i have thought that it would do as
well as it did um
it's yeah it's a lovely surprise
it's delightful surprisingly i mean
there's so many cooking shows and it
just had a lot of fun watching it thank
you
this is also a very understated
character for you she's holding back a
lot about her motives
so how did you gauge that as far as not
wanting to make her seem uncaring or
suspicious she's hiding things how did
you figure out that balance
uh well
i definitely didn't want me able to be
unlikable so when the you know when the
lines were a little dry and sarcastic i
i tried my hardest to
um
make it endearing if that makes sense um
and i find that that the moments that
were real were genuine because i would
have these moments that were so genuine
with steve and marty and my character
feeling comfortable
um with with them and telling you know
them about her life and stuff so
um yeah there's a perfect example of
that where i say to selena's character i
want you to be less mean and her
response is i know you do
are you drinking rum marty yes it's
oh rum okay i look like a rum bottle
well i appreciate you guys talking to me
i loved this if there isn't another
season you have to get back together and
do something together again because
you're just delightful so thank you
thank you you mean another another
season
in on earth because of global warming or
do you mean
with the with with the show okay with
the show
thank you so much guys thank you we
enjoyed it bye